hello everybody I'm Grandmaster Joel
Benjamin coming to you again from the
st. Louis chess club and this is my very
last lecture as Grand Master in
residence at the st. Louis chess club at
least for this this this time around and
this one is games from recent events and
it's kind of interesting it's just the
second one I've done tonight I just
finished up a lesson on the strength of
the bishop pair and the first game that
I'm going to show from a recent event
could actually appear in either lecture
because it's it's an example of both and
it's the game
that Jew and Jun 1 in the last round
against Alexandre Castel yoke in the
Cairns Cup which was recently completed
here at the same st. Louis chess club
and it was it was a it was a pretty big
game Castagna had a theoretical chance
for first place if she had won it would
have put her in a tie for first place
with hum Pekin arrow but she was playing
the women's world champion who was out
for blood
after having a huge dip drawing a
completely one position two pawns up for
nothing against Nana Hagen Itza and then
after probably sleepless night losing to
16 year old Corsa hip and a pretty
sensational game so here is that the
bishop pair in action and this is
actually going to end up being two
bishops against two knights and it's a
Berlin defense
and it's in fact the Berlin endgame
don't run away
this is gonna be good no it's not always
my favorite I actually have a very good
score on the white side of the Berlin
endgame but the reason is because I make
sure to play it against definitely
against people who are not specialists
in it because if somebody is really
adept at playing the black side it can
be be very rough all right white plays
rook d1 check one of the virtues of this
move is that it forces black to put the
King to e8 where some people like to
move to move the bishop and then play
King c8 and kind of fee and keto the K
and connect the rooks like that the
downside is that you commit the the King
rook to go to d1 whereas it's sort of
natural to play rooks to d1 and e1 and
this actually is going to to to be a
factor in this game but you know you can
you can't see the future you know it's
like you sometimes have to make
trade-offs in these moves so nice c3
Bishop d7 blacks position is very
flexible there are many many ways to
play this b3 I was never really a huge
fan of putting the bishop on b2 I
usually like to play h3 very early for
white with the possibility of playing g4
but anyway shouldn't be three this is
the thing Kettering the bishop is a
thing that a lot of people do but it
does sort of start to set up these
targets for for black which I'll say
more about but keep an eye on those
pawns
these are V the black light squared
Bishop okay
oops
that's better so so after b3 Bishop e7
Bishop b2 rook da funny thing about this
game is that after 94 this is already a
new position which is really kind of
shocking considering that these moves
are all pretty natural but but this
whole whole combination of moves is his
new white plays rook d2 maybe white
should have played h3 because I'm not so
sure that it's that great for black to
play to get h3 h4 in in the game it
actually would have probably helped
white quite a bit but after rook d2
black offers a trade with Bishop c8 and
I think that white should take block up
on that because the rook on the D file
is going to be very annoying I I don't
like to to let black have the D file I'd
rather have the King on the D file or
have the bishop retreat but castaigne
decided to keep pieces on the board
maybe because she really really wanted
to win this game as only her only chance
for for first place but now we see a
very nice idea from black rook h6 and I
think the commentators that we're
talking about how Nakamura had used this
idea but now we see that rook swinging
around on the third-ranked and becomes a
very very effective piece white plays c4
hoping to use d5 square but now you see
this this pawn chain is potentially
targets for for the bishop on C it I
talked about how you always have to look
out for that unopposed bishop and in the
Berlin endgame the LightSquared Bishop
is really the one that does the damage
usually the the dark squared Bishop
doesn't bother you although it does in
this game eventually and often why could
trade off that Bishop with Bishop g5 at
some point which you know in hindsight
maybe she wishes she would have done so
so after
see for King f8 so that gets out of the
way of Knight s6 I think white wanted to
play Knight f6 and then bring the Knight
to d5 so she when June sidestep that
rook d2 kind of an admission now that
maybe she should have traded rooks
earlier it so takes and take back with
the nine and actually took with the
knight on e4 although it's gonna end up
coming back so you see that white is
losing time and and black is my bad that
was not played black is is going to get
very aggressive in this position soon
plays rook a6 now interestingly the
commentators had Garry Kasparov on and
he was talking about the division says
rook a six forces rook a one of course
it forces rook a one to play of Kasparov
stature I think why should play rook a
one I think it's asking for it to damage
those pawns anymore
but again you know castaigne really
needed to win and she felt maybe he felt
like okay but rook on a passive square
I've got nothing going but this is a
very very serious weakness to the pawn
on b3 and white is gonna have to really
be very active to combat it so black
gets aggressive with g5 and I guess this
forces the knight really to go back to
e4 because you need to make a square
feet the other night the night comes
comes back to 2d to Knight jumps into d4
if white ever takes that that will undo
black spawns and also opens up some
scope for the bishop so the night went
to d4 and now Knight c3 so that gives
white some ideas of 95 or 95 and black
somewhat played a little controversial e
the next moves
probably just simply Bishop f5
and you know nothing is really gonna
bother black that much that that
maintains a clearly better position c6
is a little bit of a risky move because
after c6 said that weakens some squares
Knight c4 and then b5 is the move that
ends up working out really well but
should have allowed white to equalize
with with good best play 96 that was a
good move black does not want to take
that and give white that strong pass
pawn and then the other night can come
to e4 and the by position it can
actually collapse pretty quickly so you
have to you know keep that position
defended and after Bishop e6 this is
where white made probably the critical
mistake not this move but in handling
these trades this move was fine
takes and now cuz genic needed to take
this Knight right away and play Knight
takes b5 and that wins a pawn not
necessarily giving white any advantage
black could push that pawn to d3 still
maintaining the the two bishops and
quite a lot of play but white would
would at least keep us a safe position
most likely the game would enter to draw
a lot of pawns would be exchanged
so that was White's big chance but you
know an interesting feature of the
mistakes that she makes is that
Alexandra Mae maintains the option about
trading for a move and sometimes I see
this kind of mistake for my students a
lot you know where they they they wait
too long to make a certain decision and
you know what so she waited on making
this trade but now when she has to make
this trade it's much weaker that the the
D pawn is it's less under control the
white pawns or weaker
and black is getting a lot of play even
down a pawn not really a great pawn and
black has the the one pass pawn in the
position so it doesn't really feel like
white is ahead
so rook takes rook he gets the seventh
ranked Knight see for now just a
gorgeous you know two bishops move h4
this is like this is really depressing
news for white because it's like I'm
gonna be stuck on the back rank you know
the pawns ready to come to h3 and that's
going to be a permanent problem so that
was really a big move for for black to
get in really on point by jus in June
and after King f1 h3 it seems like white
is would be better off playing g3 to
make the h2 pawn hard to attack but the
thing is after Bishop d5 it's it's
really hard to find anything to play the
bishop can come to G 2 and F 3 so that
the King is just not safe on any square
and that deep one is going to be very
very hard to stop so after after h3 she
tried taking it block took back
and of course to make this trade you
want to put the King back on e1 and then
Bishop g5 this is terrible terrible news
because the bishop is coming to f4 and
that means that the white knights start
getting into a very very passive
position so the knight has to run back
to g3 it also means potentially that
ePHI pawn is going to drop but note that
black is not in a hurry to take on c4
and take on e5 and straighten out those
pawns and then you know baby white will
be able to trade that a pawn and shrink
the board so this just this there's no
hurry here for for black don't have to
don't have to do anything just yeah it
just pushes the pawn and very depressing
because what can we do if black it's
time she's gonna bring her King in so
it's Alexandra decides to kind of to
kind of make a break for it the next
couple of moves first Knight f1 King e8
it's a long way to go but just starting
Knight B to Bishop f5 defending
and now night g3 okay that beckons the
pawn to advance but you really don't
want it to king c2 and now a nice little
snack here with bishop takes e5 ok
threatening the knight Knight has to go
here oops
does not take so basically the plan for
black here is that is that she wants to
make sure that white never really
accomplishes any kind of threat so you
played Bishop f4 and you you guard that
pawn on on d2 and white tries to do
stuff with a knight but ultimately is
successful 9f one Bishop b2 attack the
knight well why can't give up h2 white
can't play Knight to e3 because of d1
and the knight and f1 drops so after
Bishop e2 what can she do Knight g3
Bishop f3 Knight f1 now a little check
ok so the King loses touch with a d1
square now she comes and attacks the
night again well Knight has to go to g3
otherwise Age 2 drops and Bishop f3
King situ but notice that black gained
to tempo it's like every time this cycle
happens black will gain a sample by
checking the king away then shuttling in
so up to king d7 we see the writing on
the wall the king is just going to
inexorably come forward Knight c3 King
c7 and you know it's at some point
around here Casteneda decides to to make
a break for a knight f1 king b7 okay
just trying to time everything before
king b6 and so she goes for the D pawn
but she loses the H pawn and that's
gonna be a very fast queen so she gets a
little bit of activity for a couple of
moves with a 995 check King takes b5 but
it's very fleeting King can go anywhere
but she decides just to end the checks
and in a couple of moves the H pawn will
queen and that's that so a really nice
win by by G wen Jun showing the power of
the two bishops White had that just one
one chance there when b5 came if she
took it the right way and and other than
that it was a you know pretty pretty
dominant game for the player of the
black pieces
Xuanzang okay there are a couple of
other important events going on one
that's that's getting near the end is
the Prague Masters where a lot of very
strong grandmasters have have gathered
in in Czech Republic but the the leader
of the tournament pretty much
wire-to-wire
Indian grand massive innit just suffered
an absolute debacle today I talked about
jus and Joe not winning two pawns up for
absolutely nothing against saga Nitza
but imagine if she had lost the game
and that's kind of how vid it feels when
you see what happened this turnaround in
this game it's really quite amazing so
vid it playing white David navara who
started off with too early don't see it
much anymore Bishop f4 vidit which
unfortunately didn't even get him the
point and people will be ready for it
tomorrow as that's how opening theory
marches on so he puts the knight on the
side I guess to take that bishop but
maybe that wasn't such a such a good
idea in hindsight Knight c3 Bishop e7
a six that move looks looks a bit slow I
have to say D 585 Bishop takes d5 and so
now he he cashes in here Knight takes g3
H takes g3 and c6
well David navara is waiving the the red
flag at the bull and the bull charges
Bishop f7 King takes f7 e six check
maybe could have come back and given the
back the P so I suppose that white would
get an advantage as he would rooks his
rooks would be very good in the middle
of the board King takes Queen e2 check
Queen a4 was also pretty strong I think
King f7 and and castles I don't think
that white that black can hold on to the
piece in the long run ninety-five check
is it's a big threat here which he can
stop with Bishop f6 but now Knight e4
happens and this this night is is
jumping into d6 really nothing to do
about that so navara gives back the
piece to be able to trade Queens
and okay material is even but obviously
white has a very big advantage in
mobilization
so I guess I guess the idea is that if
white takes the pawn and c6 he can pain
with rooks rook c8 I guess that's his
big idea so king b1 rook c8 white really
trying to squeeze the maximum out of
this advantage king b1 rook see a trick
a g1 that's the block grabs his pawn an
a3 it's gonna lose material anyway okay
I can take my check Black gets two
pieces for gets a rook for two pieces
probably a pretty good deal you know
playing against a rook against Knight
gets some pawns so but you know white
white just doesn't go for it Bishop
takes a three and he just I think takes
takes one back I take c4 c6 Bishop b4
black is really it's really tap-dancing
to avoid losing material white takes
Knight takes and then the rook comes in
to seventh rank so here's his rook
against the absolute seventh against the
King buried on the back rank just a
massive attack coming you know you can
hardly believe that why black will even
survive the the next few moves
so h5 96 okay that rook is plastered to
the back rank here C plays rook a8
double rooks on the seventh it looks
like this it's just about to win a
beautiful game right for rookie 7 rook
h7 94 okay this is a killer move the
knight is coming to f6 or even g5 and
those rooks are just going to devastate
along the seventh rank it just you know
seems hard to imagine that black could
survive so this is where you just get
completely desperate and you just look
for anything to avoid an immediate
forced win so he played rook h6 to stop
the knife from coming to f6 rook takes
g7 and rook d8 and this was very clever
because if he can trade a pair of rooks
well his position is still awful but but
he's the game's not over
however the game could have been over if
white had played rook f7 check King e8
and simply guarded the mate threat
because once he does that there's just
there's no real good defense to the
knight coming to f6
I mean black could try to defend that
but I think then then white will be able
to move rook along the seventh rank and
and and set up set up some some other
threats for instance Knight 95
I mean Knight g5 right away might be
good or you could play the rook away
threatened rook g8 of King f8 Knight g5
threatening rook f7 3987
it just looks good completely completely
devastating so so after rook d8 he made
a he made he made a big mistake that he
he allowed the rooks to be traded he
played b3 right away
and although white has big advantage + /
- we say in the business that mean
there's no mate or anything there's no
winning the rook so black keeps playing
and and somehow the more he plays the
better his position gets as a five white
plays f3
I mean maybe why should just keep
advancing the F pawn but but now having
failed at getting that forced win he
starts playing very carefully so he
brings back the rook to guard his second
rank and now black starts to activate
his position alright certainly white
could trade rooks big advantage he could
trade rooks maybe bring the King to a
three and a four
I mean looks very good might possibly
Knight win but certainly he would never
lose so just it seems like a bad idea to
me that he avoided the the rook trade
and it seems like he's just totally
floundering in this position Knight c3
rook rook to d3 Knight to be one I mean
what is he doing 95 making all these
crazy maneuvers sorry King c2 night
before check
so okay black is saying I'm it's saying
that that I'm I'm okay with a draw what
are you gonna do yeah so white tries
night 83-93 night see for I mean this
doesn't really look like a great way to
play you know the the black has really
improved his position on the queenside a
for King C - so now black is going for
another repetition and eventually white
gets emboldened you know the problem is
that it's so hard to ever accept a draw
when you position was that winning
before if you're just a little bit
better and then you get to a drawing
position you can often accept it but
this this vid it could not accept and
he's he's gradually playing himself into
a loss and now he actually starts
getting there by playing c5 which allows
black connected passed pawns
so c5 b 5 this this really happened
g4 he takes
and whites somehow thought he'd have
enough counterplay but black is too fast
he's or his pond sir how far advanced
his pawns are a - she's 6 B 3 C 6 ok so
I guess he had this idea that if rook b1
he'd go g7 and he'd be able to make a
queen with check yeah that would be one
maybe c7 first I don't know King f7 c7
takes Queen ok but that didn't happen
black said well I'm not gonna just let
you Queen and he played rook C - because
it spawns already on seventh and sixth
rank they're gonna Queen by themselves
it's a rook C to rook F one
alright trying to cut the King off but
now the rook guards it from behind and
the King takes takes care of the other
pawn c7 king daeso van that's how I
haven't had a chance to read about this
this yet but this is one of the most
epic collapses I've ever seen I mean
White was so amazingly winning and this
is a very strong player rate over 2,700
I can tell you that I don't know if I've
ever really lost a game quite like that
but I know that I've done more more
along the lines of what jazz you when
Jen did by in in drawing that that
ending two pawns up for nothing and it's
it's really just the worst feeling in
the world
and it turns the tournament upside down
because Vinit was the leader but
probably I haven't seen the updated
scores that somebody may have caught him
in the 8th round though certainly
changed things a lot okay so the last
game that I want to that I want to to
show you is from the Aeroflot tournament
which just started up they've they've
just completed two rounds
and one of the more interesting games
that I saw from the from the first two
rounds was a game won in the second
round by Ralph
ma'amed off against the hobson al a
player I'm not really familiar with but
his rating is 60 points higher than mine
so say he's pretty good players so my
mad dog is is black in this game so
so it starts out kind of slow
it's interesting that momenta of plays
this double fiend kettle because I think
that's like a great way to equalize
against a high rated player but but he
is is going for symmetry against well I
support actually his opponent is not
that much lower rated than in him but
nevertheless stuff gets generated here
Knight c3 now black decides that he's
gonna play a little bit more defensive
way with d6 rather than then d5 and
allows white some presence in the center
hmm
I believe you took with a queen
this is kind of what they call a
hedgehog formation more or less
and finally black lashes out a bit with
v5 so it wants to run white through with
this pawn all the way very aggressive
run by the e pawn now the engine say
that white is probably best off playing
f3 which might be good for an advantage
as the pawn got away at e3 but didn't
achieve any open lines so take first ask
questions later
is where we went I mean it's not
necessarily bad for for white but black
black has enough compensation because of
the of all the weak squares on the
kingside remember around White's King so
black is doing ok 95 and now the engine
says Knight g4 strong here to keep this
knight on the board and and with all the
Knights jumping into good squares white
can actually run into some trouble on
the Kings side you know those pieces can
be very strong before the night's get to
exert any power but he played bishop
takes d5 which a lot Bishop takes f6 and
white is ok after this move Knight comes
to e4 and now Queen takes b6 this is
this is not a losing move but it's a
very risky move white really didn't need
to take that pawn it would have been
better to maybe keep his Queen on on a
better defensive better defensive
position although I guess he wanted to
cover the diagonal but if he plays you
know something like Queen f4 then he
could get maybe get black 2 to retreat
the
the night or or if he plays Bishop f6 CD
5 then at least black can't or probably
isn't going to play Knight c3 here
because of the bishop but in the game
it's a little dicey for white he's still
okay but now he has to make some
accurate moves and he played king h1
which was a good move and after king h1
rook takes he - okay pieces are
gathering around the white King I would
I would be a little bit nervous if it
plays rook e1 offering a trade so the
Queen comes in now black is you know
move with two away from mating - gets to
take the knight so white really has to
has to do something
I think Knight g2 would be the most
accurate move and the computer says that
it's equal and also equality is
available with the move that he played
in the game but now he played the wrong
move with the rook but I think the right
one was not so easy to find because
apparently white should play rook f1
which is a funny-looking move to me
because black can take this night and
white takes back Queenie for his mate
but apparently white has a move which
more or less equalizes the game or maybe
maybe even gets an advantage because
black finds that he's not he's not able
to hold on to that piece that he just
took it's a weird kind of move the
combination of attack and defense
anybody see what white might do here I
mean I know I looked on the computer but
if I were playing whitest I certainly if
I were short of time I don't think I
would have foreseen it its Queen III
it's a funny-looking move it guards
efore maintains the attack on the bishop
but the weird thing is it's also got
this idea of Queen EA check and I don't
know what you do with the bishop if you
if you play Bishop g5 you actually get
mated here
yeah so so it seems like white would
have a better position actually after
after Queenie three very strange but
white didn't see that he played rook c4
so he's trying to driveway the Queen and
cover the e4 square but he did not
succeed in either of those things
because the Queen just didn't move the
bishop came to d4 so he succeeded not
getting his knight taken but he still
got problems with Queen e4 and and and
and and back rank problems after that so
Bishop d4 happened and well more or less
has to take the bishop he could give a
check with the Queen but after King g7
he still has to take with the bishop
because he doesn't didn't have any any
other good way to avoid mate so takes
Knight takes and now at this moment
white is doing okay and pawns but that
doesn't mean that he is a he's a good
endgame because his King is in a lot of
trouble and because of that he's
eventually going to start dropping
things
so tonight takes d4 white takes a pawn
so he's he's ahead for the time being
but check and he has to play King G 192
Queen B one wins it wins a piece he
asked but King g1 he gives a check then
he plays g5 so this is the problem the
knight can't move Knight G two-buck has
a choice of how he wants to do this he
can mate with the Queen coming to f3 or
he can mate with the Queen coming to e2
very fundamental so after g5 and the
knight can move so White has to do some
some tap dancing here
Queen age six he went to Penn he went
check
I think it's possible to take the night
but he he decided not to even do that
because the night actually still can't
move because the same problem Queen f3
check and that annoying Adi pawn has
been removed as in Queen h5 then he's a
lot of things he can do but he made
perhaps a surprising move he
decentralized his queen but with white
having this problem with the knight he
can't stop black from from eating pawns
and so the surprising upshot of the game
is that black wins by basically queen
his a pawn Queen takes Queen takes the
pawn and King III and he just retreats
the knight black king is perfectly safe
but the white knight is under attack
Queen e2 okay black could be a pawn up
but it decides to be two pawns up it's
not really that important to trade
Queens probably more important to get
this past a pawn going a four
I believe went to f5
okay Queenie five years Queen the tooth
that's not going anywhere Queenie for
checking it
he played h5 and that got a resignation
I guess chief for g4 is a is a big
threat if h3 he could play g4 and Knight
g5 check and take the Queen that was
interesting a little bit weird game I
like games was exchanged sacrifices I
have to admit and there was some weird
tactics at the end that rook f1 would
have been a very unusual save with the
Queen e3 move I think that would have
been you know put it pretty pretty hard
to find but you know he managed to you
know he managed to do it I mean he
didn't manage to find that the defense
and after Roxy for Bishop d4 that that
the game was pretty much over so yeah so
just two rounds down in in the Aeroflot
open in in moscow and so a lot more
action to come in in the next week
the the prague matt masters tightening
up sam Shanklin is in that event he
started with a very rough loss in the
first round two to visit as i the the
player that we saw with that that that
horrible debacle
but Sam has played a lot better after
that and he had a bunch of drawers and
then he then he he won a game and then
he got he got back into it let me see if
I
I have that game no I do not so
all right so I think we'll just just end
it there yeah so that's with the Karen's
cup ending the Masters is a is the
biggest tournament coming to an Aeroflot
is just it's just starting and after
that in March just in in just like a
week and a half the world see new team
championship will be starting up and
I'll be playing on the American team as
we attempt for a three-peat in the
50-plus division we're fortunate to win
the gold medals in 2018 2019 and we have
two new players on the team we've
managed to convince Gregory Kai Donovan
Larry Kristensen to join the fun so
we're actually we're actually getting
together a lot of the the old Olympic
team with with me and Shaba and and
Larry and and Greg and Igor Novikov
being our fifth player so I'm looking
forward to that tournament hopefully
bring back some hardware and of course
down the line I think starting right
about when I get home is the the
candidates tournament that's going to be
very exciting and they're going to do
live commentary from from the st. Louis
chess club for I think for the entire
tournament so that's that should be a
lot of fun and know that I'll be I'll be
following that so again big thanks to
st. Louis chess club for bringing me out
here really enjoyed enjoyed my time and
you know getting to do these lectures I
always like to you know try to to to pay
what to pay forward what I what I've
learned in chess
and glad to have that opportunity so
thanks everybody out in cyberspace for
watching thanks for my live audience and
I hope sometime in the relatively near
future to come back out here to st.
Louis to do this again hopefully also to
come out here to play in some u.s.
Senior Championships but it's been a lot
of fun thanks for joining me and good
night everyone
[Applause]
[Music]